hello my name is tony from famine 23
years old well Asia has been variously
interest unmade specially satisfaction
because I live vietnam developing
country and East Asia and as the young
citizen of my country in east asia i
would like to continue some possible my
interest on how to make asia one of the
leaders sorry the biggest Gators in the
world in the future of america who's
that our first division with the world
asia and age of 10 free scoop yes sure
i'll make its citizens like it let's
give people feel proud about themselves
and for example make them easier to
travel and make them harm easier to to
live to achieve the daily life and
adventures secondly it's the way you
must are we must improve and promote our
Asian cultures and ancient values among
the Asian people so that they should not
they will not pursue the amount
requested values of in the other side of
the world third acre should our client
get rid of anything and just so many bad
it's just Russian in in the comment it's
a current publication and the soul